Musique légère
*Protestations
*-Vous des incapables,
des hypocrites et des menteurs !
-C'est la nouvelle série
qui réveille
la politique française.
L'Assemblée nationale,
très chamboulée
par les élections législatives,
captive les regards,
et les députés
font le spectacle.
*-3, 2, 1 !
Cris et acclamations
-Vous êtes des incapables,
des hypocrites
et des menteurs !
-50 ans après,
vos cravates ne cacheront
jamais votre flamme !
-Nous avons le droit de débattre
et de ne pas être insultés.
-C'est votre faute,
si les agriculteurs se suicident.
-Coups de gueule,
débats enflammés...
-Ca suffit, maintenant !
-On ne vous entend jamais !
-Parfois endormie
sous la dernière mandature,
l'Assemblée s'est réveillée.
-Alors qu'elle le toucherait !
Connectez-vous à la réalité !
-C'est un théâtre.
-Je m'étais pas imaginée
une marmite bouillonnante.
-Il y a une part de vérité
dans l'excès,
un sentiment humain compréhensible.
-Le spectacle parlementaire...
-Hop.
-...est désormais permanent
et déborde sur tous les écrans.
-Bonjour à tous.
-Cette vidéo
pour vous présenter
mon activité
à l'Assemblée nationale.
*-Pas une journée
sans qu'une oeuvre d'art
ne soit badigeonnée
de soupe aux légumes.
-Les clashs TikTok ont remplacé
les duels à l'épée.
-Ce qui prévaut,
c'est l'affrontement,
toujours, partout
et sur tous les sujets.
-L'Assemblée nationale,
revenue
au coeur du jeu démocratique,
peut-elle
réconcilier les Français
avec la politique ?
C'est tout l'enjeu
pour les députés,
qui font aujourd'hui
du débat parlementaire
un spectacle permanent.
*-Vous êtes des incapables,
des hypocrites et des menteurs.
*-50 ans...
-Personnage principal
de notre premier épisode :
l'hémicycle.
Musique dynamique
-Merci,
madame la présidente.
-Avec ses sièges rouges
et ses dorures,
il est,
depuis la Révolution,
le grand théâtre
du jeu politique français.
-15 % sur les aliments
essentiels.
+15 % pour les vêtements...
-L'hémicycle,
en principe, historiquement,
c'est le coeur
de la démocratie française.
C'est une arène,
c'est un forum,
qui reprend, quelque part,
les codes
de ce qu'était la démocratie
à Athènes et à Rome.
-L'hémicycle est
le premier endroit
où on va prévoir des tribunes,
historiquement.
C'est aussi
le premier endroit,
dont on va faire
un compte-rendu
diffusé à l'ensemble
de la population.
C'est là
que va se synthétiser
la mise en scène
de cette vie politique,
donc on a
un aspect théâtral.
Il est assumé,
mais il a son rôle
dans la représentation.
Brouhaha
-Silence ! Alors...
Protestations
Oh, ce cri du coeur !
-M. Tanguy,
s'il vous plaît.
-Ce cri du coeur,
qui a inspiré
beaucoup de gens
parmi nous.
Silence, pour la France !
...
-On connaît l'extrême droite,
qui agit
comme la chauve-souris
de la fable.
Chez les oiseaux,
elle montre ses ailes.
Chez les fachos,
elle montre son poil.
Protestations
Vous vous comportez
comme des zadistes.
Vous risquez de dégrader
le mobilier national.
-Non !
Protestations intenses
S'il vous plaît.
-Avec 88 députés
Rassemblement National,
74 pour La France Insoumise
et une majorité relative
pour le gouvernement...
...
-Vous sortez en silence.
-...les rapports de force
ont changé, sur les bancs.
Brouhaha et protestations
...
Et les séances
s'en ressentent.
-Je fais une suspension
de séance de cinq minutes.
-Suspension de séance
de cinq minutes.
-Tu vas la fermer.
Protestations
-Ah, non !
Non, c'est pas possible.
Non, monsieur Serva !
C'est une invective.
Monsieur Serva, non.
La séance est suspendue
pour cinq minutes.
Pas possible.
-Je n'imaginais pas
que ce soit à ce point-là
une marmite bouillonnante,
le plus souvent,
et même à la limite
du débordement.
Sur certains débats,
il y a des éclats de voix,
le ton monte énormément,
il y a des gestes,
des gens qui se lèvent...
Il y a quelque chose
de physique,
dans cet hémicycle.
-C'est représentatif
de ce qu'est, simplement,
la vie et la culture
françaises
et même la civilisation latine
en général.
Nous sommes
une civilisation
où on exprime l'entièreté
du panel des sentiments.
Il y a une part de vérité
dans l'excès.
C'est un sentiment humain
parfaitement compréhensible,
parfaitement normal,
et vouloir aseptiser
le Parlement
pour être sérieux...
Ce n'est pas sérieux,
de nier la nature humaine.
-On ne s'entend pas !
-Quelle vision vous donnez !
-Chers collègues !
-Pour exister ici...
-Nous représentons le peuple !
-...la tentation est grande
de théâtraliser
les interventions.
-Vous êtes ravis
que nous soyons ici.
-Par exemple, en joignant
le geste à la parole,
c'est ce qu'a fait
la députée écologiste
Sandrine Rousseau.
Nous sommes en pleine affaire
Adrien Quatennens.
-C'est un geste
des féministes des années 70,
qui représente le vagin.
Il était important
de le poser,
comme un symbole
envoyé aux femmes,
qui se sont battues
pour leurs droits,
leur dire :
"Je suis là pour vous."
C'était pour éveiller
les consciences
et pour choquer.
Frontalement,
j'avais décidé de choquer.
-Certains groupes ont fait
de la provocation
leur marque de fabrique.
C'est inscrit
dans leur stratégie.
Tout ça est pensé
et organisé.
-Lorsque vous voulez
politiser l'opinion,
lorsque vous voulez
faire passer un message,
soit vous écrivez
des livres à rallonge,
que pas grand-monde
ne va lire,
soit vous décidez
de donner une portée,
en faisant
de la communication.
-On sait
qu'en communication,
un message pertinent,
c'est 90 secondes.
En 90 secondes,
1 minute 30,
vous devez être
assez offensif
pour qu'on vous retienne.
-Ce n'est plus Jupiter,
c'est "Le Parrain".
-Vous n'êtes pas
Jean Moulin,
vous êtes
des Jeanne Mouline.
-Vous mangez des Pépito
plutôt que de voter
sur le projet de loi de finances.
J'espère que c'était bon.
-Quoi qu'on propose,
vous écoutez pas.
-Tout le monde voit
que vous ne cherchez
que le chaos.
-Le chaos, c'est vous.
-Alors, je vous en prie,
un peu de modestie.
Croyez-moi, ça pourrait
bien vous aller au teint.
-Les indignations grandiloquentes,
les clash,
les petites phrases
interrogent parfois
sur le rôle du Parlement,
mais historiquement,
ils font partie de son ADN.
-Les débats d'aujourd'hui
n'ont rien d'exceptionnel.
Il y a eu des périodes
où on s'est battu
dans l'hémicycle
et où les insultes
et les coups échangés
volaient bas.
Je pense aux années...
...1880,
90, au moment
de l'affaire Dreyfus,
au moment de la séparation
des Eglises et de l'Etat.
Je pense aux années 30,
où les députés
insultaient Léon Blum.
Donc ce qu'il se passe
aujourd'hui, finalement,
se situe un peu
dans une tradition.
Ca n'a rien d'exceptionnel.
-Ce qui a changé,
c'est la résonnance
que prend aujourd'hui
ce spectacle.
Episode 2 :
comment et pourquoi
il s'invite en permanence
sur tous vos écrans ?
Musique douce
...
Le député RN Julien Odoul,
entre deux séances...
...
...aime se rendre
dans le jardin de l'Assemblée.
S'il vient ici,
ce n'est pas seulement
pour admirer
les massifs fleuris.
-On va peut-être
s'incliner dans ce sens-là,
comme ça, on voit les...
-Ouais.
-On voit l'entrée
des Quatre Colonnes.
-C'est surtout
pour se faire filmer
dans un cadre esthétique...
-On est bon ?
-...par son collaborateur.
-Chers amis, cette vidéo
pour vous présenter
mon activité
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Les débats ne sont pas toujours,
effectivement, apaisés.
-Ce jour-là, Julien Odoul
a choisi sa cible :
les députés de gauche,
dont il veut dénoncer
le comportement à l'Assemblée.
-Nos collègues de l'opposition,
comme ceux de la NUPES,
qui sont toujours prompts
à nous sauter dessus
sur un certain nombre
d'interventions,
qui sont quelquefois
de très mauvaise foi.
-Pour les députés,
ces vidéos postées
sur les réseaux sociaux
permettent de prolonger encore
les débats parlementaires.
-On peut interpeler,
on peut clasher,
on peut mettre en difficulté,
quelquefois,
soit certaines positions
des adversaires,
soit revenir sur des déclarations
ou des interventions
qui ont pu être faites
dans l'hémicycle,
donc oui, c'est une manière
de continuer le débat.
-On peut dire que
les clash TikTok, aujourd'hui,
ont remplacé
les duels à l'épée,
c'est-à-dire qu'on va prolonger
sur les écrans
ce qui, à l'époque,
à la fin du 19e siècle
par exemple,
a eu lieu
sur le champs clos,
en se battant au pistolet,
à l'épée,
et, quelquefois,
en se blessant grièvement.
-A 37 ans,
Julien Odoul intervient
sur tous les grands
réseaux sociaux.
Certains de ses messages
peuvent dépasser
le million de vues.
Une force de frappe
qu'il ne se prive pas d'utiliser,
en variant les ambiances,
les cadres et les supports.
*-Aujourd'hui,
les Verts ont une politique,
ont une idéologie
qui s'apparente au fascisme.
-Ce député est loin d'être
un cas isolé.
Musique dynamique
...
-De la cour d'honneur
à la salle des Quatre Colonnes,
l'Assemblée est capturée
sous toutes ses coutures
par les smartphones
des députés.
Les mises en scène
inspirées de la téléréalité,
de la pub ou des influenceurs Web,
alimentent jour et nuit
le feuilleton parlementaire.
*-A cheval !
J'avoue que je suis concentré
mais pas stressé, non.
*-"Concentré" ?
*-Oui, concentré pour faire
un bon discours,
que ce soit fort.
Je soutiens le gouvernement.
Allez, je pars au travail !
*-J'ai le seum.
La Première ministre
nous a remis un 49.3
sur le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale.
Tout notre travail,
tout ce qu'on défend :
pour rien.
*-Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
La France Insoumise
décide de retirer
sa proposition de loi
qui vise à réintégrer
les soignants non-vaccinés.
-La vidéo permet un accès direct
au plus grand nombre.
Pour les députés, c'est un exercice
presque incontournable.
-C'est un lieu vivant,
c'est le palais du peuple,
ça appartient à tout le monde.
Je trouve ça bien qu'une familiarité
se crée par les réseaux sociaux,
entre le peuple et l'Assemblée.
-Elue Renaissance,
Prisca Thevenot
fait partie de ces députés
qui aiment dégainer
leur smartphone
pour montrer les coulisses
des débats.
En début de mandature,
elle publie cette vidéo.
Elle montre des députés Nupes
et Rassemblement National
qui se réjouissent au même moment
d'avoir mis en échec
la majorité présidentielle.
L'extrait a dépassé
les 2,2 millions de vues.
-Cette vidéo, en réalité,
illustre aussi
ce qu'on dénonçait
dès le début de cette législature :
en réalité,
il n'y a pas "des" extrêmes,
mais il y a "l'extrême",
l'extrême gauche
et l'extrême droite.
Je pense
qu'on a besoin de voir.
Pour pouvoir retranscrire
ce qui s'y passe,
oui, il y a besoin d'images,
de visuels,
de sons, de temps en temps.
Ca permet de mettre le citoyen
au centre de l'hémicycle.
-Hop.
-Dans son bureau à l'Assemblée...
-...le député Louis Boyard
va encore plus loin.
Il possède tout le kit
du parfait influenceur Web.
-C'est très simple.
Vous avez de quoi mettre
votre téléphone,
une lumière, pour adapter
en fonction de la lumière du jour
ou de la pièce.
Voilà, vous faites votre vidéo.
L'idée, c'est pas de poster la vidéo
telle qu'elle est,
c'est ensuite de faire
un montage dynamique.
Dans les 5 premières secondes
de la vidéo,
les gens ont compris
de quoi est-ce qu'on va parler.
En fait,
on utilise exactement
ce qu'utilise n'importe quel autre
créateur sur Internet.
Nous sommes des créateurs
d'Internet,
mais on le fait
pour porter des messages politiques.
On se retrouve le 21 janvier
pour la manifestation
contre la réforme de retraites.
J'y serai
et j'espère qu'on va s'y retrouver.
A bientôt !
Musique légère
-C'est l'un des députés
les plus actifs, sur les réseaux.
A 22 ans,
Louis Boyard en maîtrise
parfaitement les codes.
Alimenter ses comptes fait pour lui
partie du travail de député,
au même titre que siéger en séance
ou en commission.
...
-J'ai commencé à me politiser
sur YouTube,
en regardant des vidéos,
sur Twitter, en lisant des avis,
des analyses,
des articles de presse
qui se retrouvaient entre mes mains
parce que j'étais
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Je suis sur Internet,
je consomme du contenu sur YouTube
qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la politique.
C'est facile de reprendre les codes
d'Internet,
car je suis un enfant d'Internet.
Pourquoi l'action de l'Etat
est-elle aussi pauvre
qu'un sandwich du Crous ?
-Comme Louis Boyard,
de jeunes députés hyper connectés
ont fait leur apparition
à l'Assemblée, en 2022.
Ils revendiquent
un ton plus libre
et assument la confrontation
permanente sur tous les terrains...
-On est entassés à cause
de la droite régionale.
*-Non, non, non, non, non.
La Nupes ne veut pas régler
vos problèmes de pouvoir d'achat.
-...quitte à heurter la sensibilité
de certains confrères.
-Vous êtes une bande de tiktokeurs
qui cherchent le buzz.
-Tout ça induit quand même
un climat politique particulier,
où finalement,
l'apaisement n'est plus de mise.
Ce qui prévaut,
c'est l'affrontement, toujours,
partout,
et sur tous les sujets.
L'image du politique
n'est pas très reluisante.
Donc est-ce que...
le recours
à ce type de communication
est de nature à rendre les élus
plus proches des Français ?
Je n'en sais rien.
-Aujourd'hui, je me pose
très clairement la question
du maintien
de mon compte Twitter.
Je reconnais
le caractère pratique,
mais le caractère pratique
s'inscrit dans un outil
dont je considère
qu'il est
en opposition
avec l'idéal démocratique,
qui est... que je porte.
Il y a un côté poubelle,
dans Twitter,
qui ne sert pas
le fonctionnement démocratique.
-Il y a une forme d'hystérisation,
de dramatisation,
de mise en scène,
de scénographie
du débat parlementaire,
donc, forcément,
tout ça conduit à modifier
la nature
du discours parlementaire et...
à aller vers des formes de,
j'allais dire,
de brutalisation
de ce débat,
qui sont pas toujours
très positives,
car elles sont pas toujours
bien comprises
et bien acceptées
par une majorité de Français.
-Comment les Français
perçoivent-ils
cette nouvelle assemblée
si éruptive ?
C'est la question
de notre dernier épisode.
Musique jazz
Louis Boyard est en route
pour l'université de Tours.
La France Insoumise y organise
une rencontre avec les étudiants,
un électorat ciblé
par le jeune député.
-Je crois que,
jamais dans l'histoire,
la jeunesse n'a été aussi politisée,
car aussi informée.
Avec les réseaux sociaux,
elle connaît l'actualité,
et elle s'intéresse
à la politique.
Mais c'est plus une défiance
vis-à-vis des institutions,
du fait que les institutions
peuvent changer leur vie,
répondre à leurs problèmes.
C'est le sujet sur lequel
on doit les convaincre.
Musique enjouée
Brouhaha
-Sur place,
il y a foule,
deux amphithéâtres pleins
et une ambiance aussi chaude
que dans l'hémicycle.
Une rumeur bruisse
dans les couloirs :
des étudiants d'extrême droite
se seraient infiltrés.
-J'ai entendu
que des fachos
étaient entrés
dans la salle,
donc je vous propose
un accueil digne,
en disant :
Siamo tutti antifascisti !
Applaudissements
-SIAMO TUTTI ANTIFASCISTI !
-Accompagné d'Andy Kerbrat,
député de Loire-Atlantique,
Louis Boyard évoque
sa vision
des débats à l'Assemblée.
-LR a gagné,
puisque, maintenant,
on porte le costard,
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Donc, vous voyez que ça fait 6 mois
qu'on se bat
pour augmenter les salaires,
donner de l'argent aux étudiants,
contre le réchauffement climatique,
eux, ils sont occupés
à nous faire porter des costards.
Faites vos choix.
-Les étudiants venus ici
sont plutôt de gauche
et intéressés
par la politique.
Depuis les élections de juin,
ils disent suivre
de plus près le Parlement.
-C'est plus animant,
quand il y a des débats,
que ça discute.
On est en faculté de droit,
et l'éloquence,
c'est hyper important.
On regarde, des fois,
ensemble,
des séances parlementaires,
donc, ouais.
-J'ai l'impression qu'il y a plus
d'interventions un peu musclées.
Si c'est que des histoires
de provocation pour provocation,
je sais pas s'il y aura un impact
qui va faire avancer les choses,
mais je pense que c'est important
qu'il y ait de l'opposition.
-Et on attend que vous répondiez
à l'appel. Donc, chers camarades,
faites mieux !
-En étant un jeune,
vous avez aujourd'hui une Assemblée
qui peut sembler
beaucoup plus "intéressante",
que les assemblées précédentes.
C'est un électorat clivé,
en réalité :
il y en a une grande partie
qui ne vote pas, apolitique,
une partie NUPES,
et également une bonne partie
qui vote RN.
Dès que ces électorats
sont mieux représentés
et que l'Assemblée leur donne
le sentiment de parler à eux,
de parler de leurs problèmes,
tout bêtement, vous avez
un effet de représentativité
ressentie bien plus grande.
-Cet effet
se retrouvent-il dans
les circonscriptions qui ont élu
des députés
Rassemblement National ?
Julien Odoul vient
à la rencontre
des commerçants
du marché de Joigny...
-Vous allez bien ?
-...dans l'Yonne.
-Vous suivez l'Assemblée ?
-Honnêtement, c'est pas super,
en tant qu'image,
parce que ça fait un peu trop...
Enfin...
Ca fait un peu école.
-Ce qui peut être
donné à voir,
quelquefois, c'est...
Y a beaucoup de cirque
et y a pas beaucoup de fond. Voilà.
Pour autant, l'Assemblée nationale
a été élue par les Français,
et ça engendre
ce genre de confrontations.
Musique enjouée
-Oui !
Oui, oui. Oui, oui,
tout à fait.
Tout à fait.
On en a besoin aussi,
de temps en temps.
Il rit.
Musique guillerette
-Ca va ?
...
Alors, l'ambiance
à l'Assemblée ?
-Y a une bonne cohésion,
on va dire, dans l'ensemble :
tous les partis sont représentés,
notamment...
le vôtre.
Et chacun défend...
ses idées,
et c'est ce qui manquait
à une république.
Quand il y a une majorité,
on est un peu piégé,
comme si les Français
n'avaient pas la parole.
-Je pense
qu'il y avait besoin
de rééquilibrage,
que les Français,
une majorité,
ont souffert de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron,
de la brutalité,
du mépris
et du manque
de représentativité,
d'avoir le sentiment
qu'ils avaient voté
et qu'ils avaient
un Parlement introuvable,
avec une majorité
omnipotente.
Donc le fait qu'ils soient
représentés par des élus,
par un groupe politique
important,
ça les conforte
et ça leur dit :
oui, il faut forcément
qu'on les défende.
-Au risque d'être
un peu caricatural,
plus vous montez
dans l'échelle de revenus,
plus vous avez de chances
de voter Macron,
et plus vous descendez,
plus vous avez de chances
de voter Le Pen.
Donc on a un électorat qui,
structurellement,
a été sous-représenté
parce que
le Rassemblement National,
pour des raisons d'exclusion
du système d'alliance,
de front républicain,
était structurellement
sous-représenté.
Donc il y a
un premier motif,
si ce n'est
de satisfaction,
de considération vis-à-vis
de cette nouvelle assemblée.
-La perception
des débats parlementaires
n'est pas la même
à Chaville.
Cette banlieue parisienne
plutôt aisée
est très favorable
à Emmanuel Macron.
Ici, le président
a dépassé les 80 %
au second tour
de la présidentielle.
-Hop !
-C'est la circonscription
de Prisca Thevenot.
-Allez, c'est parti.
-Les week-ends, elle organise
des permanences mobiles
pour aller à la rencontre
des électeurs.
-Bonjour ! On fait
une réunion publique
sur l'Europe,
si ça vous intéresse.
-OK, merci.
-Bonne journée !
Comment ça va ?
-Bien, et vous ?
-Oui. On a chaud
dans l'hémicycle,
donc on vient prendre
la température sur le terrain.
Comment vous sentez
que ça va ?
-Les gens ont plus de...
sont un petit peu découragés
sur la politique.
-Ca participe pas, là.
-Complètement.
Une période un peu chaude,
un peu tendue.
-Vous allez bien ?
-Et vous ?
-La députée rencontre aussi
des élus locaux,
comme ici
le maire adjoint.
-Comment vous voyez les choses
à l'Assemblée, là ?
-C'est un peu...
C'est un peu triste.
-C'est le mot ?
-C'est un spectacle affligeant.
-On est d'accord.
-Ils n'en viennent pas aux mains,
mais presque.
C'est le sentiment
que ça donne.
On voit même
des députés de l'opposition
qui s'en prennent
aux ministres
de façon très violente.
Il y a un manque
de respect
de notre système
républicain,
de nos institutions,
qui semble plus flagrant
aujourd'hui
que dans les précédentes
mandatures.
-C'est pas
de l'énervement,
c'est pas
de l'exaspération,
c'est un peu de lassitude.
Ils entendent beaucoup de bruit,
beaucoup de spectacle politicien,
et ils entendent très peu
d'action politique.
-Ils disent :
"C'est n'importe quoi."
Ils disent :
"C'est honteux
de se comporter comme ça."
Ils sont assez critiques,
en fait.
-En septembre,
une petite anecdote,
je visitais,
pour la rentrée des classes,
une classe de CM2.
A un moment, un gamin
lève le doigt et me dit :
"Je peux vous poser une question ?"
"Evidemment, oui."
"Je regarde parfois
la télévision
"avec mes parents, et on voit
ce que vous faites
"dans l'hémicycle.
Mes parents me disent :
"'Ah, là, c'est toujours
le foutoir.'"
Je reconnais
que l'expression
n'était pas très agréable,
mais elle n'était pas
totalement infondée.
-Vous avez une partie
de la population qui, aujourd'hui,
va se positionner
en opposition
à cette théâtralisation,
parce que
les habitudes de vote,
la perception
de la politique
vont faire
que la politique
est quelque chose
de sérieux.
Vous trouvez ça
dans l'électorat âgé
et une partie
de l'électorat centriste.
-Les débats enflammés
en hémicycle
et sur les écrans
sont les parties
les plus visibles
et les plus commentées
du travail parlementaire.
Mais derrière cette façade,
la nouvelle assemblée
fonctionne et légifère.
En un mot,
elle fait son travail.
-Si les Français
sont désespérés
du niveau des débats en séance,
ils peuvent regarder les débats
en commission,
lire les rapports,
et ils verront qu'il y a
du travail qui est fait.
Le théâtre a son importance
s'il charrie des choses
en termes
de représentativité.
Il faut pas mépriser
ce théâtre,
il a toute son importance,
mais ça n'exclut pas
le fait
qu'il y a
du travail de fond,
qui continue nécessairement
à être mené.
Il n'est pas de moins bonne
qualité qu'hier.
Il est juste moins visible.
-On ne s'en rend pas compte
parce que tout ça
est un petit peu masqué,
obstrué, si vous voulez,
par ces jeux de postures.
Donc les députés,
à mon sens,
doivent faire attention
à ne pas tomber
dans cette caricature.
-Qu'elle irrite
ou qu'elle séduise,
cette nouvelle assemblée
ne laisse pas les Français
indifférents.
La nouvelle série parlementaire,
commencée
en juin 2022, n'en est
qu'à sa première saison.
A elle de surprendre
et d'évoluer
pour ne jamais lasser
son auditoire.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA